we're told an athlete takes a deep
breath inhaling 1.85 liters of air at 21
degrees Celsius and 754 millimeters of
mercury how many moles of air are in the
breath how many molecules so pause this
video and see if you can figure this out
on your own alright now let's work
through this together so let's think
about what they are giving us and what
we need to figure out so they are giving
us a volume right over here they are
also giving us a temperature right over
here they're also giving us I'm trying
to use all my colors here they're giving
us a pressure and they want us to figure
out the number of moles we use a green
color here so they want to know so we
often use the let the lowercase letter n
to represent the number of moles and so
do we know something that connects
pressure temperature volume and the
number of moles well you might be
thinking of the ideal gas law which
tells us that pressure times volume is
equal to the number of moles n times the
ideal gas constant R times temperature T
and so we know everything here except
for n so we can solve for n I know what
some of you are saying wait do we know R
well R is a constant and it's going to
be dependent on which units we use and
we'll figure out which version of our we
use but that's why I gave you this
little table here this little form that
you might see on a formula sheet if you
were taking something like an AP exam so
we actually do know what R is so we just
need to solve for n so to solve for n
you just divide both sides by R T and so
you are going to get that N is equal to
pressure times volume over R times T our
time
and so this is going to be equal to what
well our pressure is 754 millimeters of
mercury now over here where there give
us the ideal gas or the different
versions of the ideal gas constants you
don't see any of them that deal with
millimeters of mercury but they do tell
us that each millimeter of mercury is
equal to 8 or if you get very very very
precise they are slightly different but
for the purposes of a first-year
chemistry class you can view a
millimeter of mercury as being at or so
you can view the pressure here as 754
tor so let me write that down so this is
754 tor and then we're going to multiply
that times the volume and here they give
the volume and liters and several of
these and we're probably going to be
using this one this version of the ideal
gas constant that has liters Torr moles
and kelvin and so let's multiply times
the volume so times one point eight five
liters and then that is going to be
divided by the ideal gas constant I'll
use this version because it's using all
of the units that I already have I know
what you're thinking wait the
temperatures given in degrees Celsius
but it's easy to convert from degrees
Celsius to Kelvin you just have to add
273 to whatever you have in degree
Celsius to get to Kelvin because none of
these are given in degrees Celsius and
so I will use this ideal gas constant so
this is going to be sixty two point
three six liter tour liter tour per mole
Kelvin mole to the negative 1 is just 1
over mole so I could write it like this
Kelvin to the negative 1 is just 1 over
Kelvin and then I'm going to multiply
that times the temperature so times what
is 21 degrees Celsius in terms of Kelvin
well I add 273 to that so that's going
to be 294 Kelvin and we can validate
that the unit's all work out this liter
cancels out with this leader this tour
cancels
with that tore this Calvin cancels out
with this Calvin and so we're going to
be left with some calculation and it's
going to be one over one over moles or a
success you're just going to simplify to
just being a certain number of moles and
so let's get our calculator out to
figure out the number of moles in that
breath so and I keep using slightly
different colors so n is going to be
equal to 750 four times one point eight
five divided by sixty two point three
six and then also divided by divided by
two hundred ninety four is equal to this
thing and let's see how many significant
digits we have we have three here three
here 3 here 4 here so when we're
multiplying and dividing we just want to
use the the fewest amount that I'm
dealing with so I want to go to three
significant figures so 0.01 to three
significant figures so zero point zero
seven six one this is going to be zero
point zero seven six one I could say
approximately because I am rounding but
that's three significant figures there
so that's the number of moles of air in
the breath now the next question is how
many molecules is that well we know that
each mole has roughly 6.022 times 10 to
the 23rd molecules in it so we just have
to multiply this time 6.022 times 10 to
the 23rd so if we we could write it this
way we could write zero point zero seven
six one moles all right mole times 6.022
times 10 to the 23rd molecules molecules
per mole now these are going to cancel
out and I'm just going to be left with
molecules and I can just take the number
that I had before cuz it's nice to be
able to retain precision until you have
to think about your significant figures
and so once again we're because we did
this whole calculation we're going to
one around everything
significant figures so let's just
multiply this times 6.022 ee means times
10 to the times 10 to the 23rd is equal
to that and if I round to three
significant figures because my whole
calculation that was my limiting
significant figures I have four point
five eight times 10 to the 22nd so this
is four point five eight times ten to
the 22nd molecules squeeze that in there
and we're done